hello and welcome to the lobby
gamespot's weekly video game chat show
every tuesday at two p.m. pacific right
here on gamespot com live it's also on
twitch or hello if you're watching this
on demand gamescom or youtube my name is
damien wire i'm the host of today's
proceedings joined as ever by mr.
christopher waters hey Danny how are you
doing my friend oh dear enough to go
down south yet this is a one day week
MLK Day Monday lobby day Tuesday San
Antonio the same residue per pack self
yeah and if any you guys are going to go
there should hit us up on Twitter we can
hang out at a river walk go to yellow
sounds like many people going we'll see
all the indie games there in like 30
minutes yep 45 maybe we'll see what's
gonna happen but there are actual boxed
retail games also coming out at least I
think resident evil HD remaster has a
box retail version but who better than
mr. kevin van or the reviewer of that
video game for gamespot com to come on
and tell us is there must not be a
resident known as yet I honestly don't
know I think so it came in codes not
really oh I think there it was last time
you bought a bus copy of the game a box
copy of the game a bought destiny
bayonetta 2 okay I did that's no better
20 admire your card for me there you go
the wii u still keep it a real yeah but
we're having you here today because
we're going to do a new feature today on
the lobby called ask the reviewer where
we ask the reviewer question this better
review that it this is this is scary is
it as scary is this like the comment
section come to life this is uh I don't
really know comments resilience for that
I have picked out some choice at
critiques and questions from the
comments section on gamespot com and
also from the Twitter where we put a
little post that on my Twitter at your
twitter on on gamespot as well so I
picked that a couple you've had you say
about a bad game and these are just a
sort of a selection of the various okay
okay people have you ready k yeah yeah
magic water go for it would you give the
game t i gave it i gave it a seven out
of ten i said it was good really not
very good 2 that's 3 2.5 better than
resident evil 6 oh this game that's
assault port trend Capcom it's so much
better than Reza
people say uh I'm gonna get into these
question is oh yeah and grin 89 asks a
question which actually a lot of people
were wondering about because there's
some here say about this are there still
Jill sandwiches they change some of the
games that mostly notable as far as I
know it was changed in the game Qbert
like that was that goes back to the
original but it didn't make its way I I
thank into the gamecube version and and
what this game is is it's just an HD
remaster of the gamecube version so when
your resolve all the dialogue as far as
like tells me i know jill sandwich no
master of unlocking there's an
achievement called master of unlocking
already yeah but as far as i know
there's no dialogue that calls her
master what a damn shame and to that end
caught I'll call asks how do you balance
reviewing the technical parts of a
remaster and the original experience and
I guess this kind of an even weirder
thing here because you're reviewing a
remastered version yeah they remastering
so well how do you like is it difficult
to sort of critique again based on like
2015 standards it's you know I think any
time you review uh you know re-release
it's always kind of tricky because
there's a lot of stuff going on there's
the there's the issue of how do you
review a classic you know because I
don't think of it I don't think of
reviewing a remaster or re-release as
just you know a retro game review you
know I'm not pretending that it's you
know it's 2002 now and that all of those
years didn't happen so I think it is
important to talk about like okay you've
never played resident evil one you know
what are you going to get out of this if
you don't have the nostalgia for it and
sometimes you have to remember too that
the way you remember things sometimes
it's really hard to go back to games
like you think it's a masterpiece and
then you go back to that silly little
thing you played on the NES all those
years ago we're like oh god this is crap
and what was I thinking um so it you
know it's it's balancing you know how
good is the game now after all that time
has passed how good is the remaster
itself like did they do a good job with
the extras that they threw in there are
other considerations to like other
remasters
you know like I think of halo yeah which
chris you reviewed last year and like
some of that visual stuff is remarkable
like there was a lot of stuff that went
into that I wouldn't say that this is
lives in that same category of remasters
it's it's very good the updates in the
sense that it it makes the game I said
this in the review but it makes the game
look like you remember it looking as
opposed to what it really looked like
and I think that's a triumphant and of
itself if for instance the Gamecube
re-releases never existed if this was
the first time that Capcom had gone back
to this this beloved game and this is
how it looked like that do you think
perhaps it would have been more
impressive I would it would probably
have more impact absolutely but there's
also the issue of okay so you had the
2002 remake which really is for all
intents and standards like intense and
purposes a remake as opposed to just
sprucing up you know there were new
areas and new puzzles and lots of things
that were different in brand new visuals
and there was a giant leap between what
Resident Evil One was and what remake on
gamecube was in a relatively short
period of time in a shorter period of
time than has happened between remake
yes now yeah like 12 years more and so
there's a little bit of that
disappointment in there when it's like
okay there was you know the first time
around it was much bigger bigger change
than it is now but when all things
consider this game really holds up there
are some things that are annoying now
that we're honestly annoying then so
2000 actually I've got a couple of
questions about those and light runner
trip love 07 asks I'm a huge fan of
damage and remake on gamecube and i
understand that in its time the
invitations were still somewhat there
however i honestly don't understand why
the devs didn't add the element of being
able to see what's in front of you so
one of the things that you could say
that that's something that's inherently
important in that game but say one of
the things that irk you was the loading
screen just still there with the doors
every that again so how you sort of say
what elements they should keep for
having like touchstones in the game and
what they shouldn't change
we were resumed abhi a first-person mode
might just change what resident evil is
or at least the ability to me right I
mean we're having this discussion before
I mean it resident evil 4 sort of proved
like here's what you can do to change
take this into a new territory and III
don't know like I didn't expect them to
turn this into resident evil 4 I think
that that's beyond what you should
expect for a remaster I still have to
make sure my expectations are within
what we know a product to be and I
didn't expect this to be like a resident
evil 4 type reimagining of Resident Evil
One I think that's a completely
different undertaking it sounds awesome
and now I want to play that but I didn't
really expect that to change but we were
having this discussion earlier about
like what could you reasonably expect to
change and there are a couple things
that I think would keep the essence of
resin evil one but maybe switch to maybe
waste a little less time like I'm sort
of okay with the camera angles for the
most part like it does all those fixed
camera angles they allow them to set up
each shot kind of like you do in a film
like a prop master doesn't a film where
everything is in exactly the place
that's meant to go and so they can do
that in videogame form a resident evil
with with all of these fixed shots of
course the downside is that their
annoyances especially with the new
control scheme which lets you get around
using the analog stick pointing in the
direction you want to go but the problem
is of course when the camera switches
and a great example is a puzzle that
people probably know where you have to
flip a switch the walls start going in
and you have to run around and push this
statue and get up so there's this puzzle
and then when you're when you're doing
that the camera changes like four times
as you're just going around the corner
trying to do this and your every timing
changes and then you have to sort of
adjust how you're doing looks like
there's a time limit let me just get
this done and you can use the old
control scheme but yeah there there are
some inherent like kind of issues with
the camera that happen up and but that
doesn't bother me so much I think you
don't keep the camera angles whatever i
think that's that's fine but then on the
other hand you get some things that kind
of do get annoying like I don't know
that the the door opening animations are
really adding all that much at this
stage maybe the first time you do it but
after a while like when you're in a 30
second bit of gameplay and you have to
you're doing all this backtracking yeah
and suddenly it's like over three
minutes of door three minutes of walking
three minutes of second i'm sorry i said
minutes 3 seconds that's just a long
door open else like three seconds of
door three seconds of walking after a
while that can kind of like you know
maybe maybe they could have been cut to
adds up to be a significant percentage
of your toys down to the game it's
watching a door and speaking of things
that perhaps you would have liked them
to cause and this is a kicking off a bit
on Twitter to moment Derek room and ask
the very good question yo and knowing
what's with the boob physics was not in
the gamecube version if so why leave it
in and I saw you have a discussion with
somebody on Twitter I didn't because I
sort of confirmed that that was I
because i find that was it like that
because i noticed when i was playing it
wasn't anything that stood out to me a
whole lot like you noticed when the kit
like it thank you for looping this bio
problem before the before i show star so
this is from me and Peter playing and it
wasn't until not this part but this part
is whoa but I was like what the hell
yeah and there are a couple of shots
where where those things really are
moving a bit so and it's something I
didn't remember in the gamecube version
but then again like memory is a funny
thing right and I'm not really a breast
man yeah as it were so I i went back and
i watched a bunch of footage of the
gamecube version today and sure enough
there it was it was always there so is
that something i think like you know
2015 perhaps were past the point of this
stuff like being widely acceptable by
gaming yeah i think two things have
happened number one is we're just
noticing stuff like that more because
it's mainly gratuitous um and I think
we're I think we're becoming more and
more conscious of what you know what
purposes are served by things like
there's no real purpose that that serves
we don't know more about Jill and
honestly that doesn't look all that mmm
authentic or realistic for a you know a
woman in the field to just you know I I
don't know i say to look like that's
number one I think we're just noticing
us up number two is its HD now like
something that you prop played on your
gamecube and we're watching on an SD you
know TV it probably looked a lot less
flagrant too noticeable then whereas
night now you spruce it up i I don't
know I don't
think that they've enhanced those
breasts in any way uh I just think that
now that now that it's in what we have
all the glorious pixels right there are
now in HD noticing where she has to get
acts of water yet of like actual
uniflora boobs yeah in and things like
that we do notice that stuff more the
way things move in video is oh really
but we don't need to we need read over
and this really just trying to
appreciate the environmental art here
yet is that lighting remaster is just
all All Things Considered I wedding an 8
a guy was lying right there I wasn't all
that bothered by it wasn't it really
wasn't like playing soul calibur yeah or
dead or alive or anything it wasn't like
I was just suddenly being knocked in the
head by breasts everywhere or that's a
different video but we it's available on
xbox live in DS probably yeah I did I
did I didn't notice and it makes me
wonder you know where all did jump
physics we never seen jump fish I know
when Chris Redfield I'm sure he's got
some ample package of course real life
junk physics they're really hard is that
muscley in the new skin he does look
ridiculous remember one day resident
evil 5 soft came at me and his arm was
like [ __ ] 12 times the size of
regular are you here oh yeah I remember
here because that was the year we had
the biggest biceps we had a car horn end
of the Year voting it was Chris Redfield
it was a 50 cent from blood on the stand
it was not so it was a bionic commando
dude bionic commando these guys just
like heaps of armed meet I just so
sexually had five number they were so
how did you ever shirt is this something
just cap con love doing because like the
logo for resident evil 6 at a giraffe
getting a you know he getting a bit of
the crossbow yeah the bright were a
giraffe crotches yeah Callie for my
family career who knows resident evil 7
beach volleyball here we go at Kevin
vanora thank you very much oh I'm done
there's all the bad that wasn't so bad
hey I'm going to say the least
controversial thing i'll say all day bet
it won't be creek resident evil one is
better than resident evil 6 there you go
cat i'm sure someone in the comments
finds sometimes
as well and we'll be back in a second
talking about the new border lines at
package on the Xbox one price cut but
for now let's check out the latest
trailer for call of duty yo those
zombies are fact neither wearing XO
scoops XO scooters I wish they were
scooters exosuits roll tape
when Atlas dropped the bomb they hoped
it would finish the war instead get
unleashed a freak show like no one's
ever seen what the hell get me security
I [ __ ] hate the Atlas corporation hey
what's up yeah before we actually get
into the section about borderlands could
we just appreciate what the goddamn hell
John Malkovich is doing in a video game
they have gotten the most ridiculous
cast of people to come into those cod
DLCs over the years I mean they had like
buffy the vampire slayer in one of them
yeah that is awesome but rose mcgowan
yeah Mary case she's pretty hot what's
up Danny what's up he's actually pretty
good at your son we saw the people they
get to pull into this yeah Bill Paxton
you know why not that they saw the Venn
diagram for [ __ ] call of duty fans
and the Venn diagram for from in the
building hey man independent state bans
and it turns out there was this massive
their data section and also zombies
overlap yeah it's just the sweet spot
that they didn't know that scooters was
also there so the XO school yeah
absolutely they were you going to put
zombies in it they had another with
Paxton but then they just sweeten the
deal I just want to see like some sort
of but that's it that's like the future
of like the celebrity deathmatch thing
is it's call of duty and it's like real
version skins of people like let's get
ed boon on this that show like Bill
Paxton vs [ __ ] Steven Spielberg
downloadables Denzel Washington yeah
there it's like the best part of every
fight night game is downloading ganodi
and having a fight harry potter i just-
game [ __ ] happen we tested this in a
group they said they wanted zombies
we're gonna add those in there to forget
this people having control over their
own likeness stuff that's limited our
creative expression for far too yeah
absolutely alright we talk about board
lanza yes please all rights go back to
this camera that's great just yeah it's
live experiences do whatever man come
back here hey what's up welcome back to
the lobby Mary kicks is right here
Borderlands expert Mary cash I'd say you
play a bunch of this game we I like
Borderlands a lot on big fan of the
series how do you feel about playing it
again
in a sense a HD in next gen d genndy
yeah all the hold MIDI on the xbox one
or Playstation 4 so they've announced
the handsome collection yeah which is
god it's like she pretty good it's got
borderlands 2 that's gosh bordados the
pre-sequel which only came out in
october of last year and all that deal
did you see and they're looking does it
to me like 20 different packs they had
for this there is a lot there's so much
extra yeah I think they have extra
playable characters they have actual
ease like arena sort of challenges they
have these big monster boss hunt
challenges and they have these stay more
look at this stuff yeah they have all
these 10 like these standalone story
ones with like torg and miss Scarlett it
looks a lot fancier when you put it in a
little box like that like it's it's own
somos todos like aren't will never send
a life of a great retail they were just
like extra little bit $10 packs would
you know really enthusiast you know
those are that's actually a lot of
content yeah so it's really great for
someone who really enjoys borderland I'm
if those seem like it's for the
enthusiast because they're also allowing
you to bring your save over once it's
within the same sort of family be in the
fam 360 Xbox one yeah I'm ps3 for for
ps4 owners yeah this is coming out sword
on its own sixty dollars yeah there's
another version will talk about in a
second which is insane we also have
missed a crucial point or part of this
is that you can play it split screen for
ways yes people this is like actually I
would say the only selling point so
let's do that one I mean there are no
Josh co-op games for like current day
you won't play it you as a boxful copies
that's just something that's been
happening more and more so either you
put at a great video last week where you
had your sort of like 13 best catch
co-op experience over the past couple of
years was there nothing there that was
like next-gen only next-gen available
doesn't exist really I mean all the
games now it's just such an interesting
conversation like why don't they do it
anymore it's because of the money marry
because it's a little harder in which
way people are changing on a connection
to people don't like to play local so
much yeah they want to sell no more
games they make you play together but
for people on split screen which
definitely this
something that you need current-gen to
do it's actually not possible with last
gen I mean anyone you played borderlands
with a friend you would probably have
immediately noticed there was some
severe problems with texture popping
there was framerate issues with two
people but now they can get four people
and i guarantee you i mean if nothing
else in terms of like how beautiful this
games going to look this isn't a
realistic game right so who ya i'm sure
people when they saw this we're like who
gives a [ __ ] that it looks nicer this
game looks like a cartoon it looks like
a comic but it does have edge mapping
you know it does have texture popping
you ever noticed when you play
borderlands 2 that when you switch the
weapon it was blurry that's because
they're streaming in those textures
they're not you there yet so with higher
ram means that that gun is going to look
smooth the second you copy hopefully
because like when they showed the
trailer they showed the screen for way
but they popped them all in like okay
that was probably done by a video editor
yeah I'm like one of the sort of little
annoyances about mario kart on the Wii U
is that when you did for player the
frame rate was like pretty decently
chopped down like I'm not sure if it was
halved but it was it looks so nice in
like 2 player split screen I'm a single
player but then we did it for players
like it's a constant issue is something
that borderlands actually did really
well I mean a lot of people probably
wondered why did they choose it's look
like that you know they packed a lot of
content in something that played on the
360 pretty good a New Year's i'm a last
gen system that had a butt ton of
textures and the reason they were able
to do that the developers were even able
to do that was because of the way that
they did this texture streaming and
texture lighting no do you run do you
remember that announcement because that
game looked completely different when
they first showed it off at the
Washington jail they showed off the sort
of whatever their take on that sort of
associating over to that spirit doctors
or whatever that is like it then people
were suddenly really interested in as
well so hopefully I'll be something that
looks are that hasn't run both ways as I
recall people like us made it a cartoon
game I was really hoping for this like
gritty sort of alien planet Mad Max kind
of thing and then they're like wow is it
making it all crazy but obviously that
visual aesthetic and also sort of tone
of character and writing has been one of
the key parts of borderlands success
over the
it's anonymous like they're they're
actually really you know that's just
something you think of when you think of
borderlands you think of like this wacky
visual effects and shooting McVeigh's
yeah you know do you think of these like
wacky scenarios where you're shooting
people and everything looks ridiculous
except for the water for whatever reason
they made it realistic yes so it's great
it's like the M what was the half-life 1
when they did it in source and it was
just half life but the water textures
were night before and so Mary kiss fan
of borderlands March 24th will you be
picking it up title yeah um you know I
think for the enthusiast I I definitely
have not played all the DLC I think it's
something that I would be interested in
playing I honestly wasn't a huge fan of
the pre-sequel I liked the story of
borderlands 2 better but I would
actually play through it again so i
would pick it up on its a play for for
Pearson co-op sitting all together on a
couch playing through borderlands 2 that
sounds like a weekend that is good
that's a good deal with all those xbox
one controllers that you own oh good boy
yeah you can have our players on the
screen but that's another look like 40
bucks 50 boats at the hop nobody got
more xbox one controllers yeah that's 60
bucks for the game then let's say 40
bucks for each controller that's 100 and
100 and 480 skin up why stop there why
not spend four hundred dollars on
borderlands by getting the claptrap in a
box edition which has is right there in
the title it's got drop drop in the bots
in the box it's like an RC claptrap yeah
and it comes with a clap tarap noise
that's on your phone right and that's
how you can control your claptrap and
you can see on your phone with the
claptrap sees just pretty oh that is
pretty cool and it has all his famous
lines like stairs no like we got all the
classic lines I mean when I'm sitting
around in my room full of money I
typically wonder Oh what am I gonna do
those would be read have had a little
more room here
and a little less I don't know money
maybe and maybe some way of like spying
on my roommates jacking it in the
sitting room when I'm not there yay now
my up it's a babysitter you know thanks
a lot of people put a camera in later
days yeah thanks Randy Pitchford like
some kind of teddy bear you know nanny
cam but now it's really obvious and
creepy as hell as speaking of wasting
your money there's been an Xbox [ __ ]
price drop me what else or maybe or
maybe wasting your money if you'd bought
one and in the weeks prior to this
because they've once again sort of
dropped the price down to three hundred
and fifty dollars that's fifty dollars
off the regular price this is the kinect
list version if you want to get the
woman connect slip on a custom I'm at
that time my stuff was like all right we
really need to sell some this holiday
season let's knock 50 bucks off the
price and the holiday season was over
there like cool that was massively
successful we outsold ps4 for a first
time ever let's just bump the price back
up yeah did we all did we think that was
going to stick Microsoft's did you
really think that was going to stick
they can't just let you think you have
it for fifty dollars less all the time
because then what's the point of having
it at the retail price you got to bring
it up and you got to bring it back down
this reminds me of like Vienna
nationalism stuff I bet this works like
I bet because now people are like you
know what yo it's down to 50 again I
have all that extra I gotta get bit more
cash after you know that Christmas that
December slump and you're buying all
presence of stuff and booze and
Christmas pudding I mean you bet your
ass that [ __ ] works I mean to think
about was the guy who later I heard
about this like the guy who like used to
run Sears or whatever was like I'm not
gonna have any coupons ever we're just
gonna keep the prices low it's smart and
that's the way it should be and that
dude was out of there and like a six
months because people stopped buying it
people like cutting coupons it's weird
and we can make fun of Microsoft all we
want but it's the stupid consumer that
loves the idea that they say fifty
dollars so it works like you cares maybe
this is about momentum because as you
said they sold more xbox ones than
PlayStation 4's over the Christmas break
it was also there were way more people
playing on xbox live the PlayStation
Network which is a really fun factoid
that I love because of PSN is dead
most of that five-year Microsoft still
like push that push they'll have it out
there hey the facts don't lie yeah do
you think it like it sinks especially
his playstation sort of had a bit of a
rough q4 like they didn't have that many
big games come out the only sort of main
first party game they had the came out
was a complete [ __ ] with
driveclub so do you think maybe the
momentum is with Microsoft now for the
first time after sort of a decent it
feels like six to nine months of
PlayStation having a pretty good you
know take on the market I mean I feel
like that price drop was super key for
them because that was finally yet you're
manipulating the consumers mindset like
all right it's like it's more affordable
now it's not like quite as absorbent its
349 that's way far away from 400 like
the mental barriers there do I think
that they've like snatched it back from
Tony or anything like that like no the
install base momentum for sony is still
really strong i think that that that
holiday purchase was a lot of people may
be getting their second console yea year
after their launch and you know maybe
just finally saying like I'm not gonna
buy an xbox want a full price that's
just bad fifty dollars makes a big
difference when like one of the things I
remember from working at gamestop and a
couple of other stores was that when
parents would come in looking to get
consoles for their kids then that fifty
dollars giving a massive difference
because that's either an extra game or
if there's like two siblings an extra
controller controller controller for
Borderlands for players exactly yeah
bring it back around yeah that's what I
like yeah so well I guess we'll have to
wait and see ya so if you're in more
interested in picking up an xbox one now
that the prices drop by fifty dollars or
you think it's a lot of nonsense in the
fifty-dollar shouldn't make a difference
please let us know in the comments below
all right Mary thank you very much come
on yeah appreciate it now get back to
running everything behind the scenes and
we're gonna get everything out here
that's your commercial to talk about a
fall and we do have a trailer prepared
which I'm pretty sure you know about do
you know what it is ah no it's a got
something to do with what you're doing
in with packs on saturday at 11am in the
Falcon fear
yeah hostin okay so it's about Sid
Meier's starship this is indeed yeah
gonna be hosting a panel Sid Meier's
check it out cool all right let's do it
Sid Meier starships cut to the
commercial our ancestors cross the great
void untold millennia ago pilgrims from
a dying world long since lost from
tumultuous beginnings their struggle
courage and fortitude gave birth to our
civilization for many centuries our
people prospered peace ruled our planet
and our understanding of the world
allowing us grew our scientists have
long speculated that ours was not the
only tribe to make this journey and
establish a new home on another world
but they're searching has been met again
and again with silence until now the
transmission was weak and incomplete but
in a language not unlike our own our
anticipation pool what culture and
knowledge had our brothers developed
during the long centuries of our
separation a starship was prepared
ambassadors recruited
but gradually the meaning of the message
became clear it was a desperate call for
help
galvanized by the revelation that we are
not alone our fleet has been equipped
and we are ready to answer the call of
our brethren what shall we find as we
set our course beyond the stars
febri 10th we will finally get to play
evolved from turtle rock studios and
those of you who are playing the beta
and for the past week or so have been
shouting about whether or not that game
lives up to its hype or whether it'll be
something you're in student playing just
in a couple of weeks time at chris
waters air tay you guys been playing it
in the alphas and we've had a sort of
exclusive access to it as well over the
past you know year or so just various
stage of its development and so i want
to chew it out with you guys send a
couple of weeks will obviously have
review upon gamespot eventually but from
your sort of exposure to the game over
the past year especially relation to the
latest beta and Chris first of all you
what do you think about evolved super
into it yeah yeah i've been i've been
enjoying this game since i first got to
play and got demolished by monster then
demolished someone as a monster is
really stressful but really satisfying
to like rip through some people i think
the concept is really intriguing and you
know in the limited spurts that I've
been able to play it uh it's made good
on it you know it's that it is this
unique kind of team dynamic boss fight
thing that has you know whether you're
playing as a human or monster it's a
substantially different experience I
like it have you had much experience
with playing with random people against
playing with like folks you know we've
had a couple of like in office kind of
game play tournaments of one yeah so we
like have a couple set ups here so we
try to play together when we can because
better play with people that you know
they like roll the dice but I did play
with some matchmake with some random
folks during the beta this weekend and I
did with the Alpha previously and I mean
we've definitely had some doozies like
Tay and I were in this one match with
this medic it was just like I have a
sniper rifle awesome monster head shots
all day I was seriously standing there
like I was on voice chat I was pinging
him I was like using my abilities to try
to get him to heal anybody and all we
were all running around it's like
one-third health for like seventy
percent of the match it was a debacle
but then you had that's like one extreme
then you can also get into matches where
it's like it's just someone liked a on
the other and I got a general idea how
the game flows like knows what no
splinters of his strength
knows how to communicate even without
speaking on a headset you can like leave
your little waypoints to say stuff and
so you know it's like any cooperative
multiplayer game it kind of has that
little live or die depending on your
teammates yeah so yeah it's kind of the
nature of the game Eric you've been your
know sort of stranger to cooperative
online shooter he's been playing I had a
bunch of Destiny since that came out
last year and what are your feelings one
evolved I think you're a little bit more
tempered than Chris's so for me I see
the fun factor in it I see that when we
play in the office when we're landing
together and there's generally either
all of us are hunters or all of us are
hunters and there's a monster it's kind
of more fun because I can talk trash as
the monster or I can talk trash to the
person that is a monster but then you
get those games where you do get that
one medic and we're basically screwed
right like you know you're screwed
because of this one player and that's
kind of frustrating because it's almost
like I was telling him earlier I'd
rather have a bot because this guy is
not doing his job in the bottle at least
he'll us we ran across the map
everyone's super low and we're yelling
at each other like this guy's not really
i'm about to die like I can't we can't
do anything we can't even fall in the
monster right now hell we can't even
Traverse because we might get picked off
by random by wildlife by the stuff you
can normally just shake off and a medic
tops you okay that cooked that like we
got killed by that stuff though is that
sort of stuff like just the norm would
especially in a beta when like people
aren't really new to the experience and
they might not know exactly what to do
you think this is like like you know
Gears of War week one call of duty week
one just normal you know par for the
course I mean it's the thing though is
that what call of duty or like yours a
war you have a general idea of like
we're gonna go do this right but and
evolve their defined roles right there's
a trapper there's a salt there's a medic
there's a support each plays a very
specific and defined role that's
important right like you have to do your
job or your team's going to suffer for
it especially if the monster knows what
he's doing granted evolved does do a
good job in showcasing you and kind of
giving a mini tutorial you know before
you play your character here
character here's kind of what here's the
different abilities and and different
guns that you have and it does that but
the thing is the person the player has
to utilize those things if they don't
utilize those things then your kind of
dead weight again I hate to use the
medic guy again but it's like I have a
sniper rifle so he thinks like oh I'm
supposed to snipe the monster all the
time and he's not you're not supposed to
do that right so my big thing is that it
might potentially be frustrating in the
beginning yeah part of part of like the
learning experience or playing with
randoms and I think it'll eventually get
better because like it has a leveling up
system right so the higher you level the
higher like level people you'll probably
play with I'm sure there's an MMR so at
that point the dedicated people will be
like in a level 10 15 and then you know
when you're playing with those people
they have to have a general idea because
they've they've invested time but if you
go in week one and you have multiple bad
experiences potentially that can really
make you not want to play the game like
so many people don't have that much time
anymore to play games yeah if you if you
say I'm going to sit down and play two
of all matches but you get to really bad
ones just by chance right yeah they said
look look at the draw I'm totally as you
could you could ask krista you could
also have a really great team and you
can do what you need to do let's bit of
a crapshoot but it's a bit crappy so
like if you play two bad games that
gives you this perception like oh man
like I'm just not going to get anywhere
and these people don't know what they're
doing and what maybe it's not even that
clear to you maybe it's just what the
hell how do we even have a chance
against this monster we're getting
destroyed you don't necessarily realize
that everyone's not playing to their
role and so your team is not like at
full strength you monster tears you up
that gives you the impression that the
game is imbalanced and I think balance
is so crucial to the success of this
game between the different monsters
between the different hunters because
even when we've been playing like it
events and stuff with people who have
played before when we're trying out new
hunters and new monsters like it there
have been matches that I've been like
how did what could we even have done
differently really yeah what does the
opposite ever happen because one of the
things I worry about this and like it's
easiest comparison something like your
left for dead so number one you don't
really have your classes some people you
know stay at front and some people kind
of hold back on or maybe or need a bit
more mad at me
medicine or whatever like first aid
rather every once in a while but they're
not like defined roles but the one thing
in left 4 dead is that the AI director
this is literally like a system that
Valve how to make to make sure that it
did not get imbalanced and whereas the
big antagonist in a game of evolved is a
person and that person might be really
good or that person might suck app so
what happens like how often does that
ever happen where you're just in a game
it's a complete blowout because the
individual is not a clue what to do
happen during our live stream yeah last
week we we were four hunters we know the
game and then like the monster came in
and was just like kind of knew the
mechanics you could see them doing
monster stuff but just like the strategy
of like what you need to run you need to
like not you need to know when to be
engaged or not like we were just sitting
there wailing on it were like oh this
guy doesn't this person doesn't really
know what to do now we've got them we've
got them locked sewn up you know so but
you can also play against an AI monster
like you can choose as a team of four to
go in and play co-op or PvP you can play
all this stuff solo but yeah I mean to
your point about the AI director it's
kind of like in left 4 dead even though
the area director was there to give you
some kind of scaling like there's a
bottom there's like a minimum level you
have to be skilled at or you're going to
fail like you're just going to fail and
so there it does have to be that time
when ya your enemy has to have a basic
level of competency for to be successful
but you also don't want them to be like
super ace it sounds like a lot of these
worries will probably won't be known
until the game is out and it's actually
in sort of the wider and publix hands
and to that point there are multiple
ways in which you can purchase evolve
and this I don't know about this but
this seems completely insane to me some
of the like levels of DLC that are
happening so the video game evolved yeah
which is 12 unique maps 12 hunters and 3
monsters fifty to sixty dollars yeah
alright pick up back it there you go to
video game $60 got it the whole box of
video game there is a season pass that's
normal as well sure you get three new
monsters skins they're not new monsters
right no skins yes so make them look
different
yes slightly different you also delay
have glowy bits magma magma Goliath
magma crackin and magma ratios are the
skins great yeah for new hunters these
are also skins no those are some tools
are new character hunters so you get one
for each class okay you combine them
separate if you want for seven dollars
and 49 cents yeah bit much this separate
I'm the buying separately is like
because then there you also there's also
the monster right which you can buy
separately for 15 bucks yes which yeah
doesn't I mean that makes the season
pass look a lot more appealing how much
is the season pass the season passes
2499 if you want that you can buy the
digital deluxe edition which has both
the season pass and the game just in
there together okay Sony's 80 bucks you
save a couple of save save five bucks
and save five bucks ah five bucks yeah
I'll rest you're buying individual
hunters then you're saving more yes than
that then as you alluded to earlier
there is a separate monster in the
monster expansion pack which is only
available if you pre-order the game and
which gives you the savage Goliath skin
and the behemoth when it becomes
available but you can buy the behemoth
separately for fifteen dollars if you
want okay you can still play against the
behemoth right yes so with the hunters
and the monster buying them is just to
make them playable for you got it you
can still be matched against the new
monster you can still be mad teamed up
with the other hunters uh yeah okay but
and all the maps are gone but so but
here's the question right is so like one
of the big things is like is not owning
the monster or not owning those extra
hunters are those hunters better is that
monster but you know i mean it comes
down to that and it's hey lion yeah and
it's a lot of that I hate like I hate
mobis I hate mobile is just for this
yeah the whole concept of song an
individual character yeah or skins is a
mobile concept and I don't know if it's
gonna work in this setting you can like
I'm like sure but like the color
cosmetics right it doesn't affect it
doesn't affect actual gameplay right
right look the one thing I do like is
that they're not going down the route of
say like most first person online games
where you're basically locked at like
you can play against the glyphs also all
the maps are going to be available to
everyone at all times yeah which is
there will be more maps to come but and
that won't segment the playerbase yeah
that's why which is a problem in
almost every month their shooter six
months down the line yes that it cuts
off the sort of the high-end players
with people who are just sort of like
Fairweather playing every now and again
by the way there's more versions of this
game you can play did you buy there is
the evolved monster race edition a
monster race pc monster god dammit which
comes at evolve the hunters hunting
season pass which includes the 30
seconds before new hundred and the
behemoth monster if you buy two
additional hunters a fifth unannounced
could be anything could be space monster
could be Godzilla could be goliathus
already Godzilla gah life's cuz I could
one including Godzilla dude could
guilmon could be like a spider demon
yeah I want I want a rack need monster
could be Vince McMahon could be Vince
McMahon could be Bill Clinton the NBA
jam you wanna know you're so good in a
being who knows every else waneta could
be very impressed there's not much in
the Giant Bomb Marie Antoinette cage
else we gotta kill it and for months the
skins that will be timed exclusive for
30 days so it's just like so what's in
here then is it is it the is it the
adding of more content is that the
pricing of that content or is it the
sheer articulation of different get stop
packing because when you get down to it
I don't think they're actually doing
that much wrong I like I hate DLC being
pushed before the games out because it
all makes already makes me feel it when
I spend sixty dollars you're getting
this truncated version of the game yeah
like just okay I get it and thence the
season pass let me know that there will
be stuff coming but don't don't worry at
all players always go new marine in a
way you want to buy seven dollars 49
cents look 1 x2 dual I I come on so it's
a messaging thing it's a packaging thing
like what is the best way to because is
there a way you can imagine like all
right I want to order evolve instead of
going to like gamestop I go to evolve
calm or whatever the site is and I click
to buy it like Oh would you like to add
this show a little video about what you
can get for another few bucks would you
like to add this like is it the
consumer experience because like I think
that is entirely mental thing because
it's a whole mental game trying to drive
pre-orders because pre-orders are still
so huge as metric metrics of success for
companies as insurers of a game sixth
success you know it's a certain degree
so they're trying to play that mind game
and get you to think wow it's really an
incentive for me to buy this early but
that's a double-edged sword as you
pointed out totally like that doesn't
seem to be anything they're necessarily
doing wrong but like you were saying
about the skins being like a big turnoff
for you and like for me just knowing
that there's all this game that I'm not
going to get unless I spend you know
what much is that monster race edition I
mean for me Robbie something Aaron 1900
it's not even the skins because like we
said it's cosmetic if somebody wants a
magma Goliath great good for that person
it's it's just hopefully like I said
balance because even you you hearkened
it earlier like if I don't have that
fourth monster or that extra hunter and
that hunter is better for some reason oh
it's gonna be like too much alive yeah
I'm gonna have to buy that character I
also think though in terms of the
purchasing I really hope that like they
have something built into the game like
you I wise cuz a lot of those like mobis
I mean they click the shop and it shows
you what it is you can fly it if you
want to and then I'll show you what it
does or whatever like deeper than just
store on the main menu yeah right so
who's currently it's all there they're
on for instance on Steam and when you
can't pre you could do the pre-order on
Xbox one and PlayStation 4 I don't know
it's just gotten so confusing to
purchase games and 2015 Danny does not
have that much like attention span
anymore and I don't know there's
something about it i think involved is
going to be an interesting one to see
once it hits because both in terms of
the preview coverage data like doled out
pretty significant chunks over a fairly
long period of time and also it you know
in this their their messaging in terms
of all the different iterations of dlc
like that stuff that we can sort of we
can see problems in and feel like I'm
uneasy about or you know wonder about
but is it the game then like if the game
does super well and everyone's like
having a great time playing it does that
make all that stuff okay or does it mean
make it stuff not matter as much like it
think looking back it's going to be
interesting
see how it kind of in retrospect you
know three months from now how we feel
about all this yeah the court of video
game public opinion is a very strange
place and there were all horrible
harvest parts of it and if you'd like to
leave your horrible horrible part of it
in the comments section below please by
all means do or you're going to pick up
evolve which version are you going to
pick up which skins do you want which do
you want a magma version of the lobby
which you'd be able to pay an extra five
dollars for please steam cracking yes
please steampunk Chris waters please let
us know okay I pay for that that's a
show this week gents okay will you do
for the rest of you I got the resident
evil a video review with the Austrian or
hopefully get that done today a destiny
hard modes out tomorrow hard Mohammed
raid so we might be doing some of that
look at the glow in his face when I so
happy it's been a month man I had to
wait they locked it on us yeah the kind
of space things out those you've been
doing that raid from the month and now
it's gonna be hard mode most what was
the articulation between vulva glass
regular hard I mean it was just a few
mechanics were sort of tougher the
enemies were level 32 they give them
can't die yeah oh really unless you're a
warlock then you can self res but in
normal you can get resurrect like your
teammates can resurrect you in hard mode
you die you're down a guy down whatever
say what you're on about destiny i like
i love how divisive it is but the guys
in the office guys I'm dolls who've been
playing this video game have been like
enjoying it almost consistently for like
four months now or so yeah I fell off
about a month ago but the train still
the train still keeps on rolling yeah I
would say it's unanimous that nobody
like loves playing necessarily I think
we like hanging out with each other ok I
think we're more addicted to the game
now but I think I think when we're
together it's fun to play like it's like
I got to I got to talk to Sean McCann is
young weeks ago because he was on
destiny so things like that make i don't
know i love the special can attest in
the video games smoke break let's all
hang out together yeah we notice is bad
for us the Rockets still doing it yet
makes me feel good kinda feel social and
of course we're going to
access San Antonio we're flying here
tomorrow for something on the reasons we
have to have a whole day at the Alamo d
that's true we got to go to the Alamo
can I check that out I can't wait and I
hear that's where Ozzy Osbourne ones
took a pace anything that's why it's
famous run of the many locations across
this great nation yes a very residue of
oscar for her just like it's like a
snail trail you can see the matter that
it's just yellow splash icons all over
it is so rude yeah yeah so we'll be down
there so if you're going to be in packs
s by all means hit us up on Twitter let
us know might have some sort of little
meat great drinky thing probably because
it doesn't seem like the show is that
big yeah I was looking at the map you
can see it on the pack site or whatever
and you know you can see they've got the
expo hall and they've got like the areas
that are the big sponsored booth so that
which has a big one you know they're
going to stream from there probably and
then the areas that are all they're all
like the booths are this rig and you're
like that's where we're gonna be because
that's where all the cool indie games
are yeah that's it like continually even
at prime and East last year when there's
a giant evolved monster and like I had a
great time playing it there that the
cool games you see are so much about the
indie games from next like a pick and
mix you just go in there and there's
like 60 games and you haven't heard of
ninety percent of them yeah and the
lines are sure or if the lines aren't
strober down when the lines are strong
with this right over here you come back
yeah yeah it's great I'm looking forward
to yeah we pop islands as well yours is
on the [ __ ] theater out 10 am-11 a.m.
saturday 11 on saturday yeah but Stefan
and you're doing a sort of a video
editing workshop / weird we're gonna
call it 10 top 10 video in an hour you
guys are gonna make a video in an hour
I'm published on spot really yeah just
going to be written by the people in the
audience I thought it's going to be
terrible we're going to give me a
terribly quality control excellent yeah
it's it's I'm not lie more about quality
I'm worried about content control for
nothing else in here so we'll see how
that goes that's on a2 p.m. and the same
one [ __ ] theater yeah I see after
around by all means come on down that's
the lobby for this week gentleman thanks
very much going on that's Larry Kish at
back thanks Barry thanks to Kevin
Bernard thanks ever in the back in
production and we will see you guys next
week at Tim Schafer's going to be in
talking about Grim Fandango on a bunch
of other stuff so make sure you come
back here to be I Pacific on gamespot
com see you then